taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them sorry I got distracted hey
welcome to
t-a-s-d-e buds what were you distracted
by
the pimp pimp has a thing about cocaine
sharks on the screen
and uh I guess it says cocaine sharks
might be feasting on drugs dumped out to
Florida coastline so so like cocaine
bear there's a in theory sharks getting
into drugs I mean I see by the way did
you see cocaine bear no I saw it it was
it was it was fun it was fun I think
there should be a whole cocaine series
now I mean I would I would watch a
cocaine shark movie
there I I promise you there's already
well Sharknado did all the shark stuff
but but like did you watch you know you
know the Asylum that company they do
mockbusters they're called No but I kind
of get it yeah but they did like like
when Transformers came out they did
trans Morphers okay like that that's all
they do is do like these like they do
these like like they're not even spoofs
they're kind of serious and
straightforward they're played straight
yeah but they're goofy they're like like
uh Lloyd they like trauma trauma no
trauma's way more
can't you like and like we're we're
going for the laughs and like you know
we're gonna be gross and we're going to
be insane and crazy and whatever uh
no the mockbusters they're they're head
scratchers they're they're kind of like
they just sometimes it's it's just a
straight movie that kind of rips off
something really popular that's funny
yeah look up uh
pip look up the asylum
the company's called
I got yeah here they are look B movies I
got asked to be in a shark one of the
sharknados so they did Sharknado oh they
did but Sharknado was I I think was the
first time they actually went like full
tongue-in-cheek
and I gotta be honest I don't think that
the first Sharknado was supposed to be
like I think it became a phenomenon
because it was so bad and then they
steered into the curve I might be wrong
about that but I didn't see any of them
I just saw like maybe a clip
but I think it was supposed to be wild
but like yeah but can you go back to the
to their main page what happens now
there's a tornado and it and it whips
all the sharks out of the ocean and then
the sharks are on land something like
that so the sharks are on land but they
die on land right how what is what's
going on on Sharknado this is sharks
they would land in pools and land on
people and eat them
it's so funny dude so the debts are
related to the sharks that happen to
land in a place where they can do damage
after they're out of the water
so how many sharks got caught okay wait
did the tornado wait wait go back to
Asylum
because I want to see something just
while you're saying this so well I'm
asking so pimp you've seen it is like
five six seven of them have you seen
them yeah even uh transparatory son was
in one yeah you've seen more than one
shout out Dante Palmer yeah okay great
so this is my question okay so question
number one in Sharknado one
was a tornado a regular tornado as we
know it hit and it hit over the ocean
and it sucked up a how many sharks could
it suck up was there like some time
concentration of sharks B did it suck up
any other sea uh ocean life like
okay here's this is it off the coast of
Mexico the ship of shark fin Smugglers
okay
is caught in a hurricane not a cyclone
uh interrupting his meeting with a
potential buyer a tornado throws swarms
or sharks into the boat
killing all aboard the hurricane soon
hits Los Angeles flooding the city with
shark infested SeaWorld so oh basically
okay so there's a flood they're not just
flying through the air
is that what it is there's a flood I
love that the poster says enough said
and then you're asking all these these
questions it's not enough said wait I
want to see the Asylum page though I
want to I want to keep going back it's
kind of I think it's kind of breaking
the momentum here you broke my moment
you're doing research while I'm trying
to get it I wanted to keep I wanted to
tell you about the Asylum you bogarted
and ran with Sharknado you said do this
while I look
uh well yeah and then pimp decided to
just keep feeding your thing and ignore
my request to allow me can we show this
asylum's Wikipedia page I just want to
see their other movies so I can explain
what I was trying to say that they do
yeah so they did it
off the page there it is right there
next one down next one down no go back
next one down list of Asylum films
all right so
belly fruit foreplay scarecrow so they
started these actually these initial
ones are sort of legit right
a long time this is 25 years ago yeah
somewhere in the
pimpy scroll
uh keep going
H.G Wells is war of the what like that
so that's a good example Snakes on a
train exactly but like they did like
like Pirates of Treasure Island so click
on that Halloween night exorcism like I
don't think this is supposed to be funny
they just made something that looked
like Pirates of the Caribbean I think in
order to trick people into watching it
yeah but they're not theatrical releases
are they they're streaming they were
they've always been like streaming only
well they must have a good business
model because they have 20 something
films over 20 something years it says
comedy drama but comedy drama in the way
that Pirates of the Caribbean is a
comedy drama not comedy drama like naked
gun or spoofing it right it's like no
we're making a funny pirate movie right
that is a direct rip-off
I don't know why I'm laughing at this I
actually think it's kind of shitty that
they did these things but they did them
and whatever they Loosely adapted yeah
from Treasure Island so film was
criticized as an imitation yeah
particularly as was released just before
and shares several similarities that's
another thing they would do they would
beat they would beat the release date
they would get these things out right oh
man and dude some of the some of the
posters you were like
a couple times I'd be on like whatever
streaming service back in the day and
I'd be like this is out already and I'm
like wait what is this wow yeah anyway
but they also did some legit so funny
is The Hitchhiker yeah alien versus
Hunter the 911 Commission report some of
them are legit movies 30 000 Leagues
Under the Sea freak Show like I am Omega
was I Am Legend it's just some of these
things up look at that that's seven how
many movies did they make in 2007 one
two three four five six seven eight nine
nine movies they produced in 2007. this
is there's a there is money out there to
do this kind of thing
wow paranormal entity
oh look at the poster look at the poster
yeah it's the same poster yeah what's
that one impossible pranksters what's
that
oh whoa did they rip you guys off are
you kidding I was making it oh
that would have been great that's one of
the names I've been called oh that's
great you're getting cold we get cold
every single but that's interesting but
some of their movies aren't my boss some
of their movies are just legit like
they're making a movie you know they did
a Stuart Gordon movie called King of the
ants that's actually uh I've never seen
it but it's considered to be a good a
solid movie
wow yeah they really do try to rip off a
lot of
but I think they hit
they hit hundreds of movies
actually I told you I told you the
attack of the meth Gator which is
basically cocaine oh look does it say
which movie on the in that right column
they're ripping off look says cocaine
bear wow ape versus Mecha ape which is
The Little Mermaid which is to take on
like a little mermaid some of these are
they just do their own adaptation of the
literature that already exists
The Little Mermaid's a book it's not a
Disney book it's like a real book
it might be it might be public domain
who knows I don't know then we should do
it Pirates of the Caribbean might be
public do you know this did you know
this did you know this you know why do
you know this the Amityville license
uh-huh
PD is full public domain
anybody no [__] anywhere for any amount
of money on any platform how'd that
happen in any way they please can make
because it's I think because it's just
the name of a place and you can't
copyright the name of a place so they
can go they can make a movie well it's a
one specific house that has been quote
unquote haunted the city's called
Amityville or the town
so like I know my friend Lauren works
with a guy Sean C Phillips who I'm a fan
of who's a who's got a big movie channel
on YouTube and and insta okay
but he just made Amityville the
Amityville MILF
and Abigail something else like or no
I'm sorry Amityville Karen he made the
Amityville Karen and the Amityville
something else oh that's fun but you can
just make you can just make an
Amityville movie Twilight is public
domain
no that's that's
not Twilight so
very cool very cool I'd like to go back
to Sharknado just to understand
something so pimp
[Music]
so it's driven them all up north I've
never seen so many of them yeah like
okay so it was like a tsunami okay so
the streets are flooded so the sharks
are swing through the streets disbelief
that you don't understand the premise of
this movie and need filling in
hold on
oh that's amazing
yeah like I don't think this first one
was supposed to be like that
tongue-in-cheek I think it was just like
we're gonna make this wild insane action
movie
and then after this they started to make
them purposefully funny you know what I
mean okay
so essentially what happens is there's
like a tsunami type of flood so the
sharks are also swimming the streets are
you listening to anything I'm saying
yeah are you here I heard everything you
just said you here with me yeah you're
really caught up in the Science Why
won't you let me investigate this
there's nothing to investigate a tornado
that put sharks into the street having a
dialogue why what is what is eating at
you right now I don't understand the the
obsession with the with the minutia I
want to understand what it was about so
is the are the only people getting
attacked from sharks flying through the
air because they got whipped up into the
tornado is that the only way they're
getting attacked or are they swimming
through the streets because of a flood
there's a mix of both also why are you
asking pimp like he has he saw it it
wasn't sober during it but yeah I saw
them all I saw every one of them I saw
it oh I didn't know so answer my
questions instead of Chastity
foreign
it's got nothing to do with what we do
on the show are you insane this is what
we do every single episode we're just
talking about a topic the uh I'm telling
you what is wrong with it what is your
question here I want to know that
tornado throw sharks into the air
don't attack like that is an easy thing
to grasp I get it Sharknado tornado
sharks but I'm asking just about like
well you just saw one flew at him it's
silly to me I'm just wondering if
because because where did all the sharks
come from like okay a tornado rips
through the water why is it a hundred
sharks it lifts up and why not any other
some half-assed explanation that there
was a shark migration at the same time
the tornado's hitting okay but my point
also being then this then if the sharks
are getting swept up into the tornado
the tornado is only going to throw so
many sharks it keeps moving on so all
the sharks that are in the air at one
time and when they land the Sharknado is
over
that's why I'm asking is there another
way that the Sharks penetrated the city
no I don't think so I think it's just
they get onto the land and into other
waterways and then they're here and
that's kind of the end of it if they're
in other waterways fine but from the
likes of what I've seen they're writhing
around the streets and they're flying
through the air well some of them are on
the streets that one landed in a pool
you know it's like you know
yeah you know
did but this seems a little bit this
seems a little bit far-fetched it's
I I don't care if you're doing like a
bit here to like but they expect us to
believe that that this is gonna happen
no no no they don't and you know that
they don't
and you understand what they're doing go
beyond that yeah okay go beyond that so
one tornado whips up let's call it 200
sharks now they're in midair there's
only so much time before they hit the
floor and then they die because they
can't breathe so how does the movie
sustain can't stress enough
how much I don't care about this
here well no I'm telling I've answered
the question well here's my older
countertop just got bit his his mind
I've answered the question they throw
sharks everywhere some of them land in
other bodies of water and I'm sure
there's a part of the premise is the
tornado keeps moving and throwing more
sharks into other cities or whatever it
is like that's implausible I'll tell you
I want to ask you another question for
shark Danos two through whatever worked
now the same thing happened
I had some excuse I don't know they just
they just wanted to make more so it's
important it's a goofy Bee Movie I
understand babe in part two three why
ask these questions because because it's
what you do it's a conversation about
this it's a conversation about the Goofy
movie it's a conversation making fun of
it trying to understand it I know but
it's a conversation about a movie that
has been discussed Ad nauseam I never
spoke about it in my life it's it's it's
just been this was such been discussed
this was this was such an internet thing
like it has been beaten to death so do
you want to not talk about anything that
was talked about before I think we're
digressing way too much into Sharknado a
different subject I would have been done
with my little I had a three-fold
question it would have been done already
now I'm going against I'm in Sharknado
Court I wanted to just explain the
Asylum uh based on I don't even remember
what it was based on at this point I
think the Sharknado talk is probably a
little bit more appealing to people than
the Asylum business model this is hey
babe stuff we don't do this here we
always talk before do this on hey babe
we talk personally how we doing we talk
about other food things that are
happening
a tornado hit in all the other ones too
and did the same exact thing
that that's why it's called Sharknado
too well nobody's hearing their lessons
Sharknado 4.
no because I do believe that Sharknado
then became a franchise and a brand and
if they wanted to change the story they
would need to keep it Sharknado it
becomes it's completely self-effacing
and tongue-in-cheek it's supposed to I
understand and in the in so then yeah
they do the same thing over and over
well you don't know that I I yes I I
know it from seeing the trailers of each
movie that that's what's up you've seen
every trailer yeah
this was like a big sci-fi event for
like four years I know they asked me to
be in one and I couldn't do it should
have done it maybe you wouldn't have so
many questions
uh sorry for all the apps that you're
gonna have to beep it's a lot of F's
today yeah they really deserved there's
a cinematic event it's happening again
it's happening again
Andy Dick pops up in the second one do
you see here how this works it's
ridiculous
first one be Robert Klein
first one is ex was I think was just
supposed to be Sci-fi channel
yeah like a fox
Sci-fi channel did Judd Hirsch Sci-fi
channel guys and uncut gems for Christ's
sakes that's how popular these things
were all right now I get an idea if I'm
watching this you really you needed to
see this to get an idea of what
Sharknado was yeah yeah yeah all right
maybe one of our first watches or listen
my shout out to the listeners by the way
shout out to the people that just listen
I don't know we never did I'm talking
directly to you if you just listen and
you never watch you're missing a lot of
stuff but you're just as important and
we appreciate you uh yes we absolutely
appreciate the listeners yeah yeah very
hangry today I am Eula yeah I was
picking up on something well you know
did you not eat yet
I didn't and I forgot to bring my Factor
meal with me and I'm kicking myself I
brought mine yeah well I walked
downstairs I didn't want to be late got
here
you were late you were here three
minutes before me no about ten when you
said I'll be there in four minutes that
would have netted you about now pimp and
I had a pretty intense involvement you
know what happened to me
I'm just saying I should have said the
Uber guy I gotta run back up and grab my
Factor meal I didn't do it because I
don't think of myself enough and I put
my own needs aside too much and then I
don't do what I need to do for myself
and then I end up hurting myself and
that's what I did today and now I have
no food to eat I'm very upset okay and
you think that this particular topic is
more interesting than Sharknado huh
yes I do I do I do hangry food I could
tell I came in a good mood I didn't eat
yet either by the way and I was nervous
you got your Factor meal to look forward
to I got nothing yeah with this you
could order something this snacks you
live in New York City you want a diet I
mean anything happens right when you're
on a diet sharks fly to the air in New
York City with delivery Alabama death
throw inmate James Barker Western
I'm trying to talk to you why do you
keep doing that that's bothering me
today it is Bob I'm going to the next
topic we're not doing topics we're not a
goddamn topic show I'm trying to talk to
you about life well the next time in two
weeks all right you know maybe we
connect to connect you have your partner
two weeks you're right I missed you
shouting at my face Jesus God you know
like I'm like mid-sentence you're going
Alabama what is this yeah it looked
interesting what the hell are we doing
here wow you got something wrong with
you today I'm a little you're not
connecting with me connect with me
connect babe you know what I'm annoyed
with can I tell you what I'm annoyed
with please
guys you probably heard us talk about
the game time app I love it it's what I
use now for last minute ticket deals
really any ticket deals for sporting
events concerts I mean everything you
can think of right I think it's great I
think it's great uh Sal I got I'm gonna
tell you straight up and down I don't
like the stress that goes along with
planning on going to an event no but I
like to not make a long time long ahead
of time commitment to an event yeah
that's why game time is great they're
offering The Flash Deals they're
offering the lowest price guarantees
event cancellation protection it makes
it easy to go at the last minute and go
in the best way possible it's literally
like two Taps it takes seconds to get
tickets it's so great and also they have
a game time guarantee that means you're
always going to get the best price if
you find tickets in the same section in
row as yours for Less they are giving
you a credit of a hundred and ten
percent of that difference the tickets
are sent directly to your phone so you
don't have to go dig through your emails
when you got the event snag the tickets
without the stress with game time try it
out guys I'm telling you you won't go
back download the game time app create
an account and use the code taste buds
for twenty dollars so if your first
purchased terms apply again create an
account redeem code taste buds for
twenty dollars off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
Garen
guarantee that's it
have you not wanted to sign your life
away to a big old wireless provider none
of us like it it kind of feels like
you're trapped or uh you know it's
hellish it's hellish folks nobody likes
doing that it looks fun at first
sometimes it's intriguing they throw in
a gift a free phone they'll bait you
with it yeah you know whatever it is
then you get unexpected uh bills
overages surprise fees you're stuck it's
time to get off that ride with mint
mobile now we got to try this out and I
think it's literally
the I haven't heard of anything like
this no it's for a limited time the
wireless fans from mint mobile are just
15 a month that's unlimited talk text
and data for fifteen dollars I mean
right now I'm embarrassed to say what I
was paying before I saw this deal I will
say this over a hundred bucks I will say
this what I had outside of mint mobile
right yeah the best possible deal which
was a good deal yeah and mint mobile is
making that good deal look like a chump
that's how good the mint mobile deal is
yeah it's really incredible they are
they're here to rescue you with the
premium Wireless plans for just 15 bucks
a month so say goodbye to your big
Wireless plans jaw dropping monthly
bills it is delivered on the largest 5G
Network just like everybody else use
your own phone okay with any mint Mobile
plan and you bring your phone number
over along with all your existing
contacts so don't worry about that they
make it very easy ditch big Wireless
with mint Mobile's limited time deal and
get premium wireless service for just 15
bucks a month to get your new Unlimited
Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free
go to mintmobile.com tastebuds that is
mintmobile.com taste buds cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com taste buds I have got a
big fall tour coming up big venues big
shows big fun Avenal New Jersey
September 16th Toronto Ontario September
21st through the 23rd November 11th
Philadelphia PA my hometown at the old
TLA oh classic November 17th Pittsburgh
PA bottle rocket Social Hall November
18th in Buffalo New York November 30th
Denver Colorado defense December 1st in
Phoenix December 3rd in Salt Lake City
and more dates are being added all the
time go to jodarosa.com for ticket and
venue information and ticket links I
want to see you out there please people
also guess what the album salsa windfall
artificial birth available everywhere on
August first and if you want to buy it
you can go buy it over at band camp it's
dropping August 1st on band camp a
little early so you can buy it at a
discounted rate and then it hits all the
Digital streaming platforms on August
4th I know you've been waiting for it
I'm excited about it I hope you are too
salsa windfall artificial birth hitting
those streets the first week of August
right in time for my birthday also if
you're in New York City please come to
Joey roses we're open seven days a week
starting at 11 30 a.m every day you love
those sandwiches you'll love those
drinks why don't you love them together
Joey roses
joeyrosesnyc.com I am back on tour after
that because I'm filming my special in
Chicago in December and we are going to
be at the Hartford Funny Bone the
Syracuse Funny Bone the Albany Funny
Bone all by September and then we're
hitting Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Pennsylvania Wilmington
Macon Georgia which I was corrected
about many times Savannah Athens Georgia
I'm coming through you Mount Pleasant uh
there you go and then Peoria rocked for
its Cedar Rapids Springfield Illinois
Duluth Minnesota Appleton Wisconsin
which just went on sale so you get those
tickets the still good ones Rochester
Davenport and Elkhart Indiana they're
all on sale right now they're all going
to be before the end of this year
salvolcano comedy.com for tickets and
you know what check out some hey babe
and uh some taste buds merch on our
website we got some good merch so you
should go there if you're a fan and buy
something don't be I have asked you
just hear me out I have pictures I was
in such a good mood today be in a good
mood okay you made a good mood huh I'd
say I was in a good mood I said I'm
hangry but your behavior is irritating
me right now
foreign
I have asked you so many times
whether you remember this or not believe
me it's the truth I've asked you so many
times to do a battle
of Seinfeld versus curb and every time
I've pitched it to you you've said I
just couldn't I
I would need to I don't know right
I'm not going to be here for two
episodes it looks like Joe list is
probably going to fill in for me on one
of them Joe list and Josh Nasser will
fill them that's very nice that's great
who's Josh Nasser again uh I know do you
mind comic la oh yeah Josh I'm sorry
great guy good guy uh I'm sorry Josh I
didn't remember you immediately
um anyway
Joe less comes in immediately on the
thread pitches curb versus Seinfeld you
light up you start chiming in on the
convo actually you guys had like a 10
per 10 text exchange before I went I
would agree I felt like you so was that
I felt like he deserved a I couldn't do
that and I think I feel like I feel like
your battle with list is moving very
steadfastly towards
no the reason I can't do it is twofold
one I genuinely can't oppose one or the
other I just can't so I don't know which
one I think is better I really don't
because I can make merits for both so I
don't think that I would add anything to
an argument because I could just be like
well here's a bunch of points for this
he's a bunch of points for that so for
me I don't know and then the second
thing was that I used to be and I [__]
you not
encyclopedic with Seinfeld uh I I mean I
had probably just like anyone else but I
bet you I've seen every episode 20 times
that's how much I was I could there
wasn't an episode that would come on
that I couldn't say out loud as I
watched it right and that's like that
for a lot of people but I was like
really like the next level of it and I
haven't watched Seinfeld in like a
decade and I and I feel like I'd be
doing Seinfeld the disservice if I
wasn't in the same at that same level of
knowledge you know what I'm saying what
are you gonna do re-watch the whole
series well we did I did Seinfeld you
did you did you did and I got shafted
because I took for friends
you said you wanted to take friends I
hate that I took it it was a moment of
weakness
it was a moment of weakness I shouldn't
have taken friends I hate that I want a
curb I wanted to do curb well I might
think I might argue there's reasons curb
is better and there's there's things
that are bad about curb and things are
better at Seinfeld I don't see the
debate I don't know what to
oh okay there's a debate to happen and
people would vote but for me personally
I love I can make the points I love
great points for both I love both
equally but I would defend curb because
I am curb we all that is my
you you ain't curb the way I'm curb you
ain't starting [__] the way I'm starting
[__] out in these streets I'm out there
doing the [__] he's doing
something wrong with you will curb
there's something wrong with me because
you will go to the links of
yeah I'll cross town to be like I can't
stop thinking about this I gotta get on
a plane and fly to you yeah
uh but anyway but my point is is uh I
felt a little bit in the text exchange
you didn't just SWAT him down when he's
pitched it I thought she wrote a whole
thing I think and I didn't send it
because I was like what what does this
even matter we were gonna do that but we
couldn't decide what should we so I did
Friends inside and I don't even know if
I sent that I I remember writing it I
think I deleted it because I was like
I'm wasting time yeah I just found a
little I caught a little text message
when I'm trying to do work I'll read the
text exchange I think it's very correct
I'm just saying yeah that I'm just
saying I'm just telling you I saw the
little ones I've seen that with you I
think and then we come in today I
haven't seen you and you're looking at
the screen instead of it I sent the text
to play Devil's Advocate today for curb
Devil's oh yeah that's the whole that's
how the whole curb then kicks that's
right that's kind of why I felt like you
were jumping in I almost responded to
that text Devil's ad though I could do
devil's advocate for them all day long I
I can't afford we're getting sidetracked
on on the worth of the battle versus
versus my feeling neglect from you
and feeling unloved this is this is wild
bro good piling on a lot today yeah that
seems awesome it seems also unwarrant
this is what we do yeah Sharknado isn't
that what we did okay this is what we do
okay
all right now talk about the Denver
omelette you and that
now you are you sorry I want you to look
at me for a minute let's try to talk to
you let's talk baby all right this guy
edit this talk do you believe this
I I gotta I gotta death row bit about uh
the last meal this guy had a western
omelet and hash browns is his final meal
I saw this uh yesterday why is that I'm
sorry wait why is that up news
I think it's just such a basic meal that
you can get anywhere meaning like ha
dick he could have ordered something
great and you ordered that that's not
what it is because yeah because really
the the meal is in the eye of the
the dead man walking I mean like it's
not like
I mean if somebody wanted a ham and
cheese I wouldn't be like I am a cheese
you could have got caviar like it's not
like that it's what they crave I I would
say I would say out of any breakfast
meal why is this in the news though I
don't understand it's just well it's
something what's the angle here what's
the angle it's just like can you believe
this is what he got he didn't get
Lobster or whatever
oh no that's actually in the post it's
real news
uh Alabama death throw in May James
borrower had nearly three dozen visitors
and ate a final meal consisting of a
western omelet loaded hash browns and
other breakfast fixings but whereas
Friday morning execution Barber 64
received a lethal injection uh 2 am the
former handyman's death comes two
decades after he was convicted in a
fatal beating of a 75 year old Dorothy
Epps with a claw hammer so when he was
44 he beat a 75 year old woman to death
the confessed killer had 32 visitors in
two days prior to his execution with 22
seeing him on Thursday alone he also had
two phone calls why is this news again
Barbara also requested spicy sausage and
toast in addition to the Omelette he
refused breakfast earlier but had snacks
and beverages throughout the day why
why
Barbara spent moments for his execution
apologizing telling officials I forgive
you for what you were about to do to me
I want you to tell epsis family I love
them I'm sorry for what happened no
words would fit how I feel
and then there's the there's a very high
deaf close-up picture of a western
omelette and hash browns would you think
that's his actual meal or it's just a
stock photo Getty image stock photo
underneath
um well that would that would answer it
the uh uh
[Music]
I mean Jesus Christ so again I read that
whole article the article was it just to
tell us that someone was recently
executed yeah I think it's just a kind
of an odd look if I go to breakfast with
you okay and we go to a diner which is
where bro what are you making a face I
don't know where you're going with this
but go ahead you don't know where I'm
going with this we're talking about a
western omelette I said if I go to
breakfast with you at a diner you're
confused as to where we're going with
this well I'll just because because what
would be odd of me ordering that in the
dining I don't know where you're going
yet
what is wrong with you today
you're yelling at me for nothing but
that's a weird that was a weird I don't
know you said it well if me and you were
out of Diner I'm like go ahead I wonder
where you're going you go why are why is
there a news article right right right
and I said because because I think it's
a kind of an odd last meal to get that's
still not a news basic okay and then I
said for instance if we were in a if we
when I went to breakfast in a diner
right and then you said I don't know
where you're going I don't I'm going in
a direction about breakfast but I don't
know Sharknado enough said go ahead all
right all right I'll break it down for
you yeah you know sometimes you go to a
diner you order breakfast with a friend
yeah I know how that's something okay so
let's say you and I were those friends
right doing that right and so far I'm
with you yeah okay and you got a western
omelette yeah I'd be like really
that's where you were going with it yeah
are you making a k turn because we hit a
dead end there that's that's why it's a
news story it's like the most obvious
the most it's like it's just the most I
guarantee that like who cares that 99 of
death row meals are a regular type of
food well we wouldn't know because they
don't write news stories about them but
this one made the Press
and it made the press and your whole
thing what you just went was well let's
say you and I were at a diner and you
ordered a western omelette I'd be like
oh that's that's pretty basic that was
the point I always think an omelette is
a waste of a meal always every time I
love omelets really I think they're a
little overrated they're dry most of the
time the ingredients aren't prepared
right a scramble is nice a scramble is
great Skillet yeah
uh put a put an omelette
an omelette is like halfway to quiche
but it's not quiche
it doesn't quite have the care of a
frittata even though it's sort of is one
yeah I would say a frittata a quiche or
even a a a scramble scrambles are better
than yeah that so let me ask you a
question anytime anybody orders an
omelette I'm like you're wasting a
breakfast meal right now yeah but I
wouldn't be like
hello New York Post and I got a load of
news if it was your dying meal it's kind
of a weird dying meal I would order you
know my dying meal me my three favorite
foods and they're not special be a bowl
of cereal maybe a waffle
a peanut butter and jelly sandwich and
some ravioli that's what oh peace out
God that meal sucks it's my favorite
it's my favorite meal
that's your favorite meal is a bowl of
cereal raviolis and I have two favorite
things for each meal I have cereal and
Waffles I have a peanut butter and jelly
or ham and cheese and I have ravioli and
pizza those are my six favorite foods
you're taking ravioli over Pizza you
know I'm saying those are my two
favorite like dinner foods after you
took Pizza against pasta
ravioli is my favorite you have a
problem with that too you wouldn't
surprise wow you should have taken pasta
in the pizza versus pasta battle when
you said you couldn't defend pasta
ravioli that's pasta not Pasta Pasta
ravioli is pasta no [__] pasta is
ravioli I gotta explain that to you now
I'm just saying if my favorite food fell
under the category of pasta I would
defend I just told you pizza and ravioli
are my two favorite food dinner foods
okay well I'm just saying you're saying
a lot today I am saying a lot I am I I
just I I scrap speaking of this in your
head today is something going on in mine
I would love to pull our audience live
right now you always would like to pull
the audience live but we can't so I
guess it's my word against yours once
again the scramble here we are the
Scrambler as far as a local
um uh like uh what do they call those
not festivals Fair Fairgrounds like what
do you call those things I'm going with
it when they have like you know the the
Carnegie games and the wheels and the
Festival what's it called Carnival
a local a local one you know like what
I'm getting at is the scrambler
the oh the ride yeah dude I got so
confused with what you were just talking
I thought you
I thought you were saying you go to a
carnival and get eggs and I was like
what is he talking about no I'm just
saying the Scrambler because it made me
think of that the ride the screen yeah
how do you rate that ride in the in the
realm of those types of rides uh I'm not
a fan
I'm not a fan why it's like the the
Gravitron no I hate the Gravitron well
the Gravitron I respect more because at
least it it there's a it has a feat to
it
the fetus don't throw up
but it's like you're gonna spin so fast
you're gonna defy gravity and like weird
shit's gonna happen in here that's very
interesting never never been on one
never will go on one oh it's it is kind
of wild like what happens inside of it
oh it's disgusting why is it disgusting
because it's it's just fully nauseating
you're just going in there and getting
around until you can't your brain can't
handle it anymore but like I've heard
stories people get splattered with throw
up on that thing I've heard of stories
of people throwing up and the throw up
stays in the air like it's wild like
it's but yeah I hear you I have no
interest in revisiting the Gravitron
right oh my gosh I'm talking this is
what you have no interest in reading
this is what but that's wild but I just
repeated every word no but to look at it
a screen as somebody's talking to you
and started dressing are you insane it's
what we do here that's the screen we
look at it during our conversation
you're wild bro we're talking about this
specific topic he brings up it gets
stuck upside down on a roller coaster
for three I go oh wow and you get mad I
heard everything you said it's I would
find it
it's it's it's I would find it wildly
rude if we were having a conversation
and you did that yes I'm sorry yes I
find it rude earlier I was breaking
balls because you just got hooked on a
thing I didn't give a [__] about and you
just wanted to talk about it I thought
you were just breaking balls I was
busting your chops that was legitimately
very rude what you just did
yeah
all right don't take the note go through
life anyway
I like a scramble because it is it is
wait the crap let me finish my thought
about the gravity please I'm dying to
hear it all right I was saying you're
not dying to hear it I know sarcasm when
I hear it no no I'm not here what I was
saying you you're telling me right now
that I'm not dying you're not dying to
hear your thoughts about it what I was
going to say at least a Gravitron has an
element to it that that's like a little
like mind-boggling like that already
yeah right this but I don't want to go
on the Gravitron the only reason I'm
giving it the edge over the Scrambler is
because of that element both rides
however I'm not a fan because the only
goal is to make you dizzy and sick
that's what I'm saying the Scrambler I
think is palatable I think it's it it it
it toes the line of like all right
you're gonna whip you around but it's
gonna be like silly fun
you know I mean you don't get sick on it
I mean if I write it ad nauseam maybe
but like one one ride on it I get off
and I'm good I might be misremembering
that Whip and then when you're passing
someone else it looks like you might hit
him and then you whip like it's funny
yeah it might be misremembering the
Scrambler being too more dizzying than I
that I remember yeah okay all right fair
enough what do you think of a of a Dutch
uh
I was a dutch oven I'm a touch
the boat the Dutch boat whatever it's
called oh the the like the buccaneer
yeah why is that a Dutch boat
I feel like a Dorney picture hold that
ride the Dutch boat I think it was
called The Dutch something at the Dorney
Park and Wild Water Kingdom the
buccaneer I think is great although if
you if you want to give yourself a quick
Google on Buccaneer accidents there
are horrifying
on Buccaneer accidents yeah like when
the thing won't stop or it almost goes
all the way around or the thing is on
what it's wobbling because the weight is
Shifting the thing's not anchored oh and
those people they can't stop the ride
and they're just like on that thing
whole it becomes like a real Buccaneer
like in the like a perfect storm hey
when you were a kid so did you read uh
that book uh everybody pooped I did
I had not when I was a kid but I have
right yeah yeah I read it for a college
yesterday yeah or maybe you read it to a
kid recently who knows you know let's
just say many adults like us have
forgotten the details pooping anxiety
self-controlled constipation and nervous
diarrhea these are conditions that many
adults experience look at me look at me
in the face if you are out there and you
have pooping anxiety or self-control
constipation or look at me nervous
diarrhea you're heard you're seen yes
okay we see you and that's where seed
comes in seeds ds01 makes it easier to
go okay what about when you gotta get on
stage and you have the anxiety and you
have to go to the bathroom and be like
oh my God now I can't go and I gotta
this is an hour and you have this
nervous stomach up there yeah I know
seeds DSO one uh daily symbiotic
supports healthy regularity healthy
mobility and ease motility babe or
motility excuse me an ease of evacuation
there's also increasing research on uh
the gut brain access which seed is
currently researching and partnership
with axial Therapeutics the capsule and
capsule via cap safeguards viability
through digestion for delivery of an
average of a hundred percent of
probiotic starting dose so you're
getting you're the full dose you're
maximizing everything out of that
capsule yeah that's really great 16 of
the 24 strains are specifically geared
toward Digestive Health uh and that
makes sense because people take a
probiotic for Digestive Health uh
reinforces healthy stool hydration and
ease of evacuation which you just said
yep and supports gut ease from
occasional gastrointestinal discomfort
associated with
increased increased intestinal Transit
time is what I was trying to say
everybody hang tight we're taking it to
the end
anyway start a new healthy habit today
visit seed.com tastebuds and use code
taste buds to redeem 25 off your first
month of seeds dso1 daily symbiotics
today swear oh they've been taking it
yeah that's great yeah that's great it's
wonderful uh yeah this is these are
areas I need help in and seed is the
place they're the folks to help uh
that's seed.com taste buds use promo
code taste buds God health is important
check it out
folks want to talk to you about raycon
raycon raycon raycon making amazing
earbuds to kick up that summer
experience for you I love the summertime
I love the summertime Vibes I love the
sun I live also in New York city so I am
walking around all the time not just
because it's beautiful outside but
because I got to do a lot of stuff on
foot and I like to have my own
soundtrack as I do it whether I'm
running errands or walking to a work
thing whatever it is I like listening to
music and raycon is making that the best
experience for me for you for all of us
you can use the earbud tap functions to
toggle between three customizable sound
profiles noise isolation and awareness
mode raycon they've got 32 hours of
battery life including eight hours of
play time so you can listen to what you
want when you want for a really really
long time and they come with the custom
gel tips for the most comfortable in-ear
fit also best part to me raycon starting
at half the price of the other premium
audio brand fans but they sound just as
good Ray comes also coming with a 30-day
happiness guarantee so you really can't
lose I'm telling you people even if
you're not going on vacation Summer's
all about a vacation State of Mind get
there with raycons create your own
soundtrack right now with raycon taste
buds listeners can get 15 off their
raycon purchase at buyraacon.com taste
buds to save 15 on your raycon order
that's by raycon.com taste buds so
create your own soundtrack right now
with raycon right now taste buds
listeners are going to get 15 off their
raycon order at buyraacon.com taste buds
that's by raycon.com taste buds to save
15 off on raycons buy raycon.com
taste buds my friends Scott and it was
either Scott and Tim or Scott and Tim's
brother Pete I can't remember which two
but it doesn't matter but Scott
they did they he liked to go on every
ride that was like
the more terrifying he got excited he
did a ride I remember it was I think
again it was at Dorney Park this was the
ride right and Wild Water Kingdom and
Wild Water Kingdom yes see now you're
locked in and I like it
Tim's brother Pete wow you don't you
don't need to flex now now I'm locked in
and I'm [__] nobody needs to
flexible now I'm paying dedicated
attention to every word you're saying
and I'm flexing all right all right
you today you're not gonna you can't you
didn't have your V8 I didn't have my V8
you can't lock into everything exception
today everything's an issue I got up
maybe it's the testosterone kicking it
[Laughter]
it was like I don't know I'm gonna say
200 feet in the air 300 feet it was
wildly tall
I don't know how many feet that is right
okay
but it was wildly tall it was it was
like tall enough that if you fell off of
it you would die right it was that tall
anyway
it was a poll it was a straight pull
that's it there was a designated car
here
and a designated car at the top of it
car two cars enclosed like a vehicle
like a like a car like a like a ride car
right doesn't it fully enclosed car
fully enclosed yeah yeah I got that like
how they did one of those like the
London Eye like that kind of thing yeah
locked doesn't move just there at the
pole designated one facing this way
bottom of the pole one facing that way
the whole ride was you and a friend sit
in the car and the thing just starts
spinning I know it so you go up and then
the thrill is you are going face down in
this car right from 200 feet in the air
whatever it is down
and they did it I was like there's no
way I'm getting on that and they got off
and I was like was that scary and they
were like dude it was absolutely
terrifying yeah and I was like I don't
understand rides like that other than
your your it's like bungee jumping I
don't get it I have a fear of heights
okay and within that fear of heights
I've jumped out of a plane once in 2006.
I've bungee jumped maybe 10 times a
bunch of Action Park where you jump
backwards and there's a there's a pad
down there in place it was riddled with
accidents oh God yeah I mean you'd see
people bleeding and getting carted out
every year when we went really yeah I
bled I mean I I you would see multiple
accidents a day
every time you ever went for the course
of my channel can we please can we make
a note for a shirt
please all right Roger squeeze my head
we have to get we have to get Roger to
say we should make a shirt he says I
bled at Action Park
that's a great shirt I bled at action
park but it's very Niche it's it's just
gonna be sold here Niche it's for our
podcast fans who else should we try but
if you're not from Mount Vernon New
Jersey no no there was a documentary on
HBO called class action park right yeah
but I think it's more I think Action
Park is more Infamous than you think it
is but in order to be like I bled there
Roger squeeze my head I blood at Action
Park yeah all right um I have I bungee
jumped I did the bungee jumping where
they tie it to your leg your ankles and
then you dive Face Forward at that
Tuesday in action park Fat Tuesdays in
Cancun
all right that makes a little more sense
to me to do it because it's Fat Tuesdays
you're in Canada you're over the water
and you got yeah you're over the water
you also you got a head full of rum and
tequila or whatever that was bad and you
know my friend Gary I would never do it
again just because of my I don't know
what I was I guess when I was younger I
didn't have as much of a fear maybe it
was terrifying and I've since seen paid
a picture jump accidents you're at the
top of this thing
it's okay so it's so there's Fat
Tuesdays they have an outdoor area
that's on the water so it's part of
there and you go and then on the beach
but like on a pier is a rickety like
like staircase of wood
and it's a it's a genuine company like
you sign a waiver and they say we
haven't had an accident and you know all
that you know that we haven't had any
accidents and are you sure are you
trembling I well we all a bunch of us
did it and I was drinking jobs probably
I don't know what I was I was 21 20. I
mean two years South
I don't know if I was there yet I don't
think I would have done it like that I
just think I was like but you were you
got a good Buzz you're like you you're
in you're in Cancun baby
there when I was doing this really yeah
I wouldn't have done it I don't know I
don't know I remember being of sound
mind a bunch of us did it they and they
tie and they tie they put a towel on
your ankles so that the Rope doesn't
hurt you
and then they clasp it and you dive
forward this is the technique I would
never do it right my friend ties it to
his ankle he's drunk my buddy Joe and he
jumps off just jumps off feet first so
that by the time he gets to where the
Rope is going to give his bodies upright
but the Rope is tied to his legs that
rope he looked like a human rag doll
when he jumped off Pete first we were
like waiting in a line up there like
waiting room to go and like we just all
went and we looked at the the Mexican
guy though like who was like the the guy
who worked there and he was like
he just jumped off and we were like oh
and then when he got to that point he
went and he just his body it looked like
his limbs were going to all fly off did
he get hurt he was okay but we couldn't
believe it but I also so he hits the the
Rope Titans with him feet first and it
just goes just whips his body down
it it was I've never seen a human body
like in that crazy it sounds like you'd
like break your spine and we would we
were like this we were like running we
were gonna run downstairs because we
were like he's gonna need help and then
he was okay
anyway let's hold on a second that's a
great story yeah that's a great story we
gotta [__] we have to get to the battle
we have to get to the battle
look my clock's ticking all right
um what do we have Tim so okay all right
battle here we go ready yeah type two
b-a-t-t-l-e Buzz we on the same page
we're on the same page we have the same
page good we'll screw you because now
we're battling okay now we're off the
same page all right all right sore
throat runny nose which is worse
no no yes I was saying sore throat is
worse you're saying runny nose well
stuff knows what we put up there but I
think what we're saying is like a jacked
up nose stuff you're not maybe I mean we
did for the vote we did put stuff stuffy
nose nothing in my entire world when it
comes to sick
is worse than sore throat
because I will tell you I can steer into
the curve of any other aspect of sick
and quite frankly they're both horrible
find a little enjoyment
if I'm not if I'm being honest I don't I
don't follow all right if I'm achy and
fatigued
I'm like this sucks but I'm like I guess
you gotta lie down all right it's time
to lay in bed there is something about
that achy shiver
that like it's fun to like get under the
covers and I it's probably worse than
the chills the chills is the worst the
chills chills I forgot about the chills
well that's for another day well I heard
that you were feeling ill headache fever
and the chills what's that from I came
to help restore your pluck
because I'm the nurse who likes to oh
what's that from weird Weird Science
you're you're in the area you're in the
neighborhood Better Off Dead
you're in the neighborhood
revenge of that urge you're in the
neighborhood
Dodge me Dodge me don't give it away
nudge me nudge me nudge me all right I
had something to say but it'll give it
away
Ferris Bueller yes that's right all
right so yeah that's a dead giveaway
yeah anything you there's not one Ferris
beautiful thing you could have said that
wouldn't have been a dead giveaway yeah
if you would this is the one thing you
could have said
uh you could if you went nine times no
that would have dead giveaway with your
bad back you shouldn't be throwing
anyone
that I might not have got oh I had with
your bad back
she's the best that lady is awesome in
everything she's ever in yeah she's the
best yeah you could hey what do you
think this is man what country do you
think is this you know they're making a
prequel movie about those two guys oh
boy do I
I I'll reserve my comments because it
sounds like you might know the people
involved in the project I'm once removed
all right never mind anyway so here's
the thing I can steer into I will tell
you this it's cool because it's the same
day
so it's what was going on simultaneously
no no I get that I love that idea I get
that it's the same day yeah
maybe it'll be great I don't care about
those two characters I just can't give
me a Rooney give me Rooney's day I care
about the universe you know give me
Rooney's day
give me Jennifer Gray's character's day
well you kind of saw her day
give me you saw their day the Parents
Day the parents I couldn't care I get it
they took the car they had an adventure
there's a story to tell yeah all right
maybe it'll be great yeah anyway let's
uh
I'm available for parts
five and over uh anyway you're gonna
land that one yeah well you never know
the thing about a sore throat is right
but wait wait I can steer into the curve
okay
of the aches I can steer into the curve
of a fever all right I'm just going down
for the count this is it oh fever's bad
sucks but I can steer into the curve of
it okay
um
even stuffy nose there's a satisfaction
in blowing it out runny nose
satisfaction and cleaning it sore throat
when it happens
it there is nothing positive at all you
can say it hurts when you eat it hurts
when you drink it hurts when you talk it
hurts when you're doing nothing it
absolutely sucks
there's it keeps you awake
there's that feeling I hate it I hate it
it's the worst I hate it and I and I
probably arguably hate it maybe just as
much as the stuff knows I took stuff
notes because I can make an argument for
both stuffy nose
um
there are measures right you can gargle
with warm water and salt there are
mentholyptus cough drops uh that really
oh a numbing like kind of zinc lozenges
talk to the CEO of holes and tell him
that ludens doesn't do anything but
gluten's it we could all agree ludens
we've been on to you since childhood
you're a candy factory posing as a as a
loss you've got a real you got a real
but holes brings it brings brings in the
noise brings in the funk okay holes you
can get an extra in holes that you'll
put Menthol in here and feel it in your
bowls babe babe
I don't know who you think you're
dealing with I buy Halls by the bag okay
but let's be honest you got a real sore
throat in your hands all that Halls is
doing and saying have a little taste of
honey with some mentholptus it'll
distract you for a little while it's
like the thing about it is you need to
have almost almost Hall after Hall
it's yeah and and it becomes a little
hard to have that many Halls you're also
but that's why you switch off then you
have some tea you have a little honey
and lemon and you gargle those things
maybe you take an Advil over over a
period of time may may do a little bit
of assistance but you look none of those
things will cure us yeah but the stuff
he knows Afrin baby no no no no it's so
potent no no no no you can only do it
for three days or you get addicted for
Life correct and I don't do Afrin
because it's it it burns your nose it's
not good for you and you can't do more
than Africa clears the noses it's
temporary relief at best when you have
so it's a horse
right by the Halls is not I mean Afrin
is bad a hole you're not gonna be like
I'm addicted I'll suck your dick all
right okay then shoot a fed or you know
there's decongestants that decongestants
that work there's DayQuil there's um uh
well there's there's medicine for all of
them but sore throat is its own if you
have you can't breathe you can't taste
food you can't talk right you can't
sleep you can't sleep even more so
because you it's okay okay swallowing is
one thing but you need to breathe if you
have to breathe out of your mouth for
like three four days straight because
you can't get rid of this stuffy nose if
you have to speak you want to sleep well
if you want to taste food it's so good
it's so annoying I think you cannot find
me through your nose I think you're
combining
stuffy nose
with the other elements that sometimes
come along with it
but here but no no hear me out hear me
out here's what I'm saying but can I
just only one point before you continue
just one point yeah with with a stuffy
nose it eliminates the function of the
nose it eliminates it right a sore
throat you could still swallow against
the lead it just it just hurts but you
could still have the function of your
throat but shout your your talk this is
and this is the point I was about to get
to you're talking about a concrete was
poured in my nose stuffy nose that only
happens one out of every
for me and I have allergies for me one
out of every 20
scenarios we're not no we're not we're
talking you just said when you have a
sore throat all bets are off you can't
breathe you can't eat you can't swallow
I think any level of sore throat is
horrific but that period but but that's
my take that's why I said I pick sore
throat that's why I think it's any level
of sore throat and it's the worst thing
in the world stand it I can't stand it
not to mention it it's an indicator that
something far worse might be wrong or
something very bad might be wrong strep
throat it's a sign of strep throat strep
throat oh uh sound like you said shrub
it could be the sign of a bacterial
infection it can be a sign of different
viruses stuffy nose is usually allergies
okay usually and my point is is unless
it's worst case scenario which is one
for me out of every 20 stuffy noses a
stuffy nose is usually sort of
irritating but you can breathe you can
taste you can do this there's no hiding
it you go to a function you go somewhere
you're like hi everybody
that's worst case scenario right
arguing just worst case scenario not
arguing the merits of how severe one can
be versus the other that's silly what's
the worst the the most annoying thing
about a stove you can't breathe through
your nose but you can breathe through
your nose it's just harder to breathe
you I you would literally have closed up
nostrils you can't breathe through your
nose you have to go like this and try to
read and then you can't that's an
extreme scenario is what I'm saying but
when I say stuff he knows that's what
we're all talking about right when you
can't breathe through you know I I what
I'm saying now you're telling me Oh well
I'm talking about uh the case of stuff
he knows that I had last week where I
kind of could breathe no I'm talking
about the I'm talking about what stories
then I'll talk about worst case scenario
sore throat you literally can't swallow
so then what are you gonna do
when was the last time you couldn't
swallow you literally when you have a
true worst case scenario you cannot eat
solids because it will irritate the
throat you can only have certain fluids
because certain fluids will irritate the
throat
a cold that's not true you can't have it
but soup
listen hot liquid I have allergies I get
stuffy noses a lot the scenario again I
will say it again one out of 20 is the
scenario where I feel like there's some
rubber cement in my nose and I can't
breathe usually what are you talking
about I I understand so that versus a
sore throat it's not then then I gotta
argue worst version of sore throat
that's fine that's what I thought okay
that's what I was just doing and you're
saying it's not valid because it's too
random I didn't say that's not valid I
said when was the last time that you had
a sore throat where you couldn't
physically swallow
I don't know the last time it seems a
little crazy
it also seems crazy to me to go that I
get stuck did you die
oh dude I don't like it did it hurt to
swallow or could you not swallow when
you have a true strep throat sore throat
it is very hard and painful to swallow
yes of course you physically can do it
right but you try not to sure because
it's horrible and yes you can't eat
because Foods or irritate the the
infection and the throat and the the the
uh uh you know what I mean the soreness
it's like it's like hitting a bruise or
something over and over again and it
won't heal so you have to so so I will
take not being able to eat solid foods
any day of the week over I can't smell
yeah
soup is delicious oh please so it's an
immediate alleviation hot liquids you
have you have this is a you're not bad
you have a lozenger a lozenge you have a
uh you have soup you have honey lemon
and tea you you have you have you have
chloroseptic you went to you could spray
it right in your throat and numb it
immediately if you want to go with
Africa because you dug your heels in on
worst case scenario stuffy nose you're
you're not giving you're not allowing
yourself now The Wider breath of the
argument you could be making against
sore throat you're you've painted
yourself into it sure I am I just named
you 10 ways to alleviate that it's not
ciao when you have have a real sore
throat because there's a there's a
bacterial infection you have to take
medicine for it let me ask you this they
don't do anything let me bring this to
the table
what's the ratio of times that you have
that type of sore throat versus the
times you have any type of stuffy nose
what do you get more and in any in any
way shape or form stuffy nose stuffy
nose 20 to one right again 20 to 1
stuffy nose I will say it again so 40.
say it again for the four times a year
because I might have a sore throat
I'll take that and remedy it versus the
50 times a year that I can't breathe
through my nose
you you if you can't breathe through
your nose 50 times a year you have
allergies
yeah and you you've yet to let me finish
the point you just keep saying what I'm
saying is not true I have allergies why
did I say anything was not true
oh my god when did I say anything
let me say this let me say this without
you going but that's not worst case
scenario that's what you keep doing when
I say I have allergies and this is how
my allergies are you go but that's not
worst case scenario I'm talking worst
case scenario that's what you're doing
what I'm saying to you right now is this
I have allergies they plague me
throughout the year when I go to places
that have shifting pollen counts it is a
very bad experience for me that said
when my nose gets stuffy it is seldomly
so stuffy that I literally can't breathe
through it it's annoyingly stuffy okay
which goes back to the point I was
initially trying to make 10 minutes ago
which is I think you are coupling the
version the worst case scenario version
of stuff he knows with things that come
along with that because it's an all-out
onslaught allergy attack meaning there's
also scratchy throat there's also ear
itch or whatever and all these other
elements I've never brought a single one
of those up nor had I said anything
outside of not being able to say you
brought them up
attaching all of those things to the
stuffing let me explain I think in your
head you're associating well with my
nose is that stuffy oh it's so horrible
and it's like well when your nose is
that stuffy there's a lot of other
things going on with it and it it's it's
it's not a really great barometer to
judge stuff he knows by in my opinion
most stuffy nose scenarios are able to
be fixed or eradicated through some kind
of nasal spray that isn't Afrin if you
don't want the most
dangerous of my thing is outside of
shooting after up your nose nothing
cures the stuff he knows you've never
taken not suitable
but the the sinus you know uh uh what's
one of the other sinus things well I
mean we're gonna say we could take
medication to alleviate it sure you
could take medication for either of them
I'm saying if it goes unchecked right I
mean we could we can have medicine for
both of them I'm not saying I mean what
kind of battle would it be if I'd be
like stuffy nose is terrible but I could
take medicine so there's no argument
here
um all right let's see let's go to the
phones our guests for the next episode
is here but let's go to the phones and
see what some people are saying
I would rather if it's not dripping down
my nose enough to deal with a sore
throat eating drinking speaking all
terrible with a sore throat thank you a
bad enough stuffy nose can cause a sore
throat that's not true because stuffy
nose or runny nose would because then
you would have a drip sore throat
legitimately ruins everything inability
to swallow is far worse than being
forced to breathe out again slaughtered
hold on you read two comments I read
four
how do you know all four of them said
sore throat by a landslide
uh if my throat were soaring through the
sky something would be oh shut up Sal
misspelled sore okay that's what they're
referencing oh did I
I was doing it on the fly yeah I won a
spelling bee so
that was me defending you I don't like
when people make little jokes like that
stuff stuffy nose I can still give
blowies with a sore throat
I'll die of Suffocation if I have a
stuffy nose that's interesting she's
they're applying a during oral sore
throat hurts bad and is such an
inconvenience give me the stuff you know
stuffy nose I can breathe out of my
mouth sore throat everything hurts
eating until it's gone come on here if
Sal
if Sal is saying this is a tough one so
far it's 100 sore throat no no I saw one
or two stuffy noses stuffy nose is worse
there you go because I can't comprehend
where the body thinks restricting my
breathing is helpful
you mean sure okay with a stuffed nose
you can at least breathe through your
mouth no relief oh boy all right yeah
you might be getting killed here you
know what pimp let's just code it up so
I already voted so when I scroll up it
will be in
okay yeah yeah I mean I'm gonna get I'm
getting my ass handed to me here
think positive
wait let's
drum roll here and pimp has we got a a
pretty wide margin of victory for sore
throat 67.3 percent to stuffy nose at
32.7 that's after
30 000 votes
30 000 votes so that is
that is uh cemented for sure for sure
um yeah I mean what I was going for is I
have a stuffy nose I have a stuffy nose
I would say truly truly I would say five
times to one that I have a sore throat
so if I had to eliminate one I'd rather
have a sore throat five times a year
than a stuffy nose 25 times a year that
was my logic obviously it was not seen
by everyone uh do you see what I'm doing
though you're doing some type of uh
dance that has no rhythm to it well
there's no music playing okay
but just a natural Rhythm it didn't have
either I don't need to do anything all
right
uh it's a comeback dance this is your
season season three is your season
she'll love you I love you too taste
buds they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them